Sông đầu chung đông đặc biệt là tại Yavien Hông Mút đang tăng động chữ tiết tưởng quần công khi tưởng nhé thoại lòng là nơi nơi ngơi tăng cầu.
Một số tỏng trở là nơi ngơi đã thay đổi lộ trình, chuyển hướng từ châu Âng sang chóa, nhằm đất bình như cầu giá tăng,
đã có những kinh tế như nhẹ bản hành của ở đây loàn.
Giá là nơi ngơi tại chóa và chóa, đã tăng mạnh kỳ tư khi các thẳng thẳng bùng phát, phát là những áp lực từ việc bận tài và phân phối bị gián rạc.
Tại trò bôn đã giúp kinh nghiệm từ cuộc hùng hoảng năng lượng, anh nhìn không trai mi hai, đã vùng cái điều khoảng hùng đồng linh hoạp và mất phát cao hơn,
nhằm hạnh chế việc có lo hàng lần nữa gờ bị chuyển hướng.
Các chuyển ra những mạnh, khả năng thiếu hồ lần nữa gờ tòn cầu của tỉnh gia tăng, nếu sản đoạn tại Hô Mút kếm sài, đồng thời cạnh máo rằng
khi lần nữa gờ khó lưu chữ và phận chuyển hương dòng mỏ khiến cái tị trường dễ biển hưởng bởi các khu xóm mùnh công,
các nhà xúc hổ lớn như Mỹ và cơ ta đang được kì vọng điều trình của mừng nể các mạnh thình trường.
Đồng thời các niềm khảo phải tăng cường cơ trị thay thay và dữ trữ.